was kind of a dream of mine for a little
bit to live in San Francisco
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello world
it's Saturday Scott and I went out for
the first time in like years yesterday
right yeah we went up to Oakland for my
friend from high schools birthday and we
even went to a club which was fine we
got home at like 1:30 after a
traditional stop at McDonald's to get
very usable snakes they don't got
Mexican food up here like they do we are
now on our way to our friends house to
do what play board games and then go to
a play yes the kid young adults go
clubbing I go to a playlist and see him
to my for our period can't wait Scott
yeah Scott you're 30 now there's what
you do in your search
[Music]
heck that hi what do you think it was a
play last night I think I've now a more
awake because it's quick you a because
yeah it's definitely woken me up be told
none of us really liked the play because
it was just like a single person
monologue for like an hour and a half
about existentialism which was fine but
human experience yeah the human
experience but it didn't really feel
special
but I was cool we went and it was fine
and then we went back and played some
more board games when we came home last
night at around 11:30 I am off to
Cameron's just go now you'll hang out
with a friend then we'll have a fun
chill time right yeah thanks for doing
the dishes
welcome okay
[Music]
so it turns out that I went to the
completely wrong one so now I'm gonna
try this scooter towards the other one
because otherwise it will take me 20
minutes
I haven't actually written a scooter and
I survived it was actually super fun and
all my scooter riding from back in my
Scandinavia honey one day is really paid
off so I just finished hanging out with
my friends in the mission we went to a
really nice chocolate place which I
found out from my friend marina about it
being one of the best chocolate places
in San Francisco it was pretty good
we got like their hot chocolate and it
kind of tasted like sake interestingly
maybe there's something related between
chocolate and sake that makes the taste
that way but now I'm on my way to the
other side of the city to go hang out
with Scotts grandma and Scott there and
then go home afterwards
foot in fact about San Francisco it's
like only 7 miles wide so it's pretty
small but it does take about like
anywhere from 30 to 45 minutes to drive
in between I don't know if you can see
just the houses that are passing by
right here but they're so gorgeous and
they're so pretty and I love looking at
them
San Francisco was just so nice I love
being up here I haven't been here in a
while actually and it was kind of a
dream of mine for a little bit to live
in San Francisco but it's really hard to
find housing especially with the dog so
it never really worked out a lot of my
friends live up here in San Francisco
and I worked up here for a little a long
time when I was working at patreon but
it's just so nice I like I think the
people who live in San Francisco tend to
all be really pace it's just really
tough living here sometimes good I feel
like the income disparity can be really
stressful because you see a lot of
homeless people in the city granted
there's a lot of parts of San Francisco
that doesn't have homeless people but I
mean you can just really see that
there's like a very strong like economic
stressor that is put onto the city as a
result of the tech industry so I think
for that reason it's just been harder I
guess for me to want to move up here
because I don't know I don't I don't
think I think I would just spur a lot of
my anxiety and I know that I might part
the problem a little bit
but it's just like it's it just doesn't
make me feel good and I want to feel
good about where I live but it's also
like the state of America where no
matter where you live right now housing
prices are really expensive and income
disparity is really big so in some ways
you just kind of have to live with it
but I just wish that weren't the case
one way one direction one direction so
they have to be try otherwise they won't
stick or they won't like stay inside
[Music]
with a car now with the current Howard
war if you put the flower on there and
then do this yeah you can make it thin
yeah well yeah it doesn't stick to
itself
hmm good you want oh you you roll ahead
yeah yeah what y'all doing down there
yeah
okay enjoy it wait what well you're on
top nice with the oil yeah yeah it's
pretty thick on
[Music]
Wow how's it going Scott is this rough
it's not very circular no it's okay it's
getting it wrapped up anyway
[Music]
hmm
ah yes but that into this part
[Music]